lucifer is the show that just can't stay
dead
having been brought back from the brink
twice but the devil you know has a lot
more lurking in his backstory than you
see on his tv show
we are here to break down lucifer's long
and complex history
myth obsessed writer neil gaiman took a
history of mythic fiction and ran with
it in his legendary sandman series
which maps out a whole cosmos for dream
its brooding protagonist to travel
as one of the endless immortal
anthropomorphic embodiments of concepts
like destruction and desire
dream moves through the world of myths
and gods as easily as our own mortal
plane
at some point he ends up in hell where
readers first encounter lucifer
ruling over his realm of eternal torment
sandman's take on lucifer pulls heavily
from john milton's paradise lost
the first major character introduced in
the epic poem
lucifer is a fallen angel who rebelled
against god deciding that he would
rather quote
reign in hell than serve in heaven
milton's work follows a defeated satan's
plan to corrupt mankind in another
attempt to get one over on god
sandman borrows the charisma and tragedy
of this take
but moves away from any direct relation
to man this lucifer morningstar is
concerned with himself
and his nemesis above all else he does
fairly little in regard to corrupting
the souls of humanity
at one point a damned human points out
that his title
lord of lies is a bit overblown and that
lucifer doesn't take an active role in
guiding people to help saying
he doesn't lie at all he tells you the
exact literal
truth and then he lets you find your own
way to help you see what i hate more
than anything is a liar
a charlotte someone who doesn't believe
in what they say
the fact that lucifer is known for his
underhandedness irritates him massively
as he rants to dream he has never made
any human do
anything despite how often people claim
otherwise saying
they can live their own tiny lives i do
not live their lives for them
and then they die and they come here and
expect us to fulfill their desire for
pain and retribution
all this hints at a larger problem the
ruler of all damnation
is deeply unhappy about the way his
eternal life has turned out he has begun
to view hell as a stagnant place
completely out of line with his own
radical ethos as mike carey
writer of the standalone lucifer comic
series which spun out of sandman
explained it lucifer is unable to stick
to the comfortable in the routine
saying we play safe most of us do most
of the time
but lucifer doesn't know the meaning of
safe and he never bothers to look down
at the tramlines
with that in mind it's clear that
lucifer's time as ruler of hell
came with an expiration date when dream
journeys to hell to retrieve a spurned
lover he discovers a nearly empty place
lucifer meets him
explains that he has quit and hands over
the key to hell
dream doesn't hold the title of ruler of
hell for long however he turns hell over
to loyal angels in the service of god
who continue the practice of tormenting
wayward souls
rather than carrying out these
punishments for the enjoyment of the
demons who once filled hell however the
new angels
view punishment as redemptive while
admonishing a bloodthirsty
demon mid-torture they say that was the
old hell
that was a place of mindless torture and
purposeless pain
there will be no more wanton violence no
further suffering inflicted without
reason or explanation we will hurt you
and we are not
sorry because afterward you will be a
better person
it's only in the face of horror that you
truly find your noble cell
how does the tortured soul feel about
this that makes it worse
that makes it so much worse in the
meantime
lucifer sets up shop on the mortal plane
hell might continue on
but his part in it is over using his
incredible powers of persuasion
lucifer quickly becomes successful on
earth he ends up settling down in los
angeles where he opens up a piano bar
called lux
and runs it alongside mazakin a demonic
daughter of lilith
though he's been freed from hell after
billions of years lucifer still can't
let go of his anger
specifically his frustration surrounding
the problem of free will
if he feels a predestined path exists
for all creation then all sin and
missteps are part of that plan
making eternal punishment unjust indeed
if god built the universe to ride on
rails then lucifer's own rebellion was
planned by god
that makes his own expulsion and
punishment a grave injustice
and troubles notions of sin and free
will eventually it is revealed that
lucifer was not sent to hell by an angry
god
rather the space was a concession from
the creator
allowing a rebellious angel to get as
far from the light of heaven as possible
hell built itself around lucifer's whims
god did not construct its many horrors
though lucifer knows this
he does not let on to his underlings the
lie of his banishment
is the only one he allows himself to
tell the lucifer comic series
starts with the devil happily retired
but he can't outrun the watchful eye of
heaven and its angels
their continued intrusions into his life
post hell
eventually boil over and he falls back
into his old ways of attacking god and
his loyalists
after again reaching a stalemate with
heaven he decides to create his own
bubble universe which will be
outside of god's jurisdiction because
lucifer creating a universe of his own
an outrunning god would negate the
creator's supposed omnipotence
the entire host of heaven comes down to
try and stop him
lucifer and mazakin fight hard to create
their space
with lucifer continually turning up his
nose at the entities who act as pillars
of the current universe
he holds the most scorn for destiny of
the endless
he sees dream's brother as the
embodiment of god's love of
predestination
lucifer makes it clear that his new
universe will be based around the idea
of free will a figure like destiny will
have no place there
ultimately lucifer is unsuccessful in
his attempt to create a new universe
realizing that he would have to return
to creation and thus
god's rule lucifer throws himself out of
the known universe entirely
as in the similarly cosmic dark tower
series the man who wants to leave the
universe is pursued
god follows lucifer leaving his throne
behind to chase down his errant son
lucifer's niece a young girl named
elaine bellick
assumes the throne of heaven to keep the
entirety of creation from falling apart
to keep things tidy
the world rewrites itself around the
current inhabitants of creation
effectively making it as though the old
god never existed
hell is rebuilt around the remaining
demons and the universe soldiers on
meanwhile lucifer is in the void beyond
creation surrounded by
all that is and never was as he is
engulfed in chaos
god approaches him as any father might
approach a wayward son
god tries to comfort his most
cantankerous creation
to no avail he then offers to merge with
lucifer
becoming two entities god claims that he
wants to close the gap between lucifer
and himself
so that he might finally understand why
lucifer felt so compelled to rebel
and says each of us would be the hot
metal to the other's mold
lucifer could be born again no longer
the fallen angel and adversary of the
world
going along with god's plans is anathema
to lucifer however
though he'd managed to destroy god's
predestined universe as it existed he
can't imagine agreeing to any suggestion
god raises
lucifer tells his immortal father this
face is mine
this scar is mine you may not have them
not with my permission
lucifer opts to throw himself into an
endless void of nothing
rather than go along with god's plan god
tells him to go
and that he will not see him again the
series ends with lucifer melting into
the blank white page
beyond god's reach at last lucifer
returns from the void
several years later to team up with an
unlikely partner
the archangel gabriel who spent eons
battling the prince of hell as one of
god's most favored servants
needs lucifer's help to solve a murder
mystery fit for nietzsche
god is dead and they need to find who
did it gabriel has been cast out of
heaven and can only return once he's
found the killer
a series of twists and turns carry the
brothers across
nearly all planes of existence the
sibling rivalry between lucifer and
gabriel
simmers in the background of this
noirish story which
seems to straddle the tone of the three
lucifer properties
sandman the previous comic run and the
tv series
ultimately it's revealed that gabriel
killed god and had his memories of the
event
wiped though the archangel is somewhat
horrified
it's obvious that years of living under
god's rule have chafed
and his time spent with lucifer has only
further pushed him from the ramrod
straight morality of heaven
he pokes at lucifer saying that he beat
out his brother by
being the one to finally go all the way
i'm much worse than you ever were
at least i've got that the version of
lucifer morningstar
fancy on tv cobbles together bits and
pieces of all of his former incarnations
because it began as a network show on
fox it came in the only language that
gritty television seems to speak
police procedural at the outset lucifer
has abandoned hell to build a nightclub
in los angeles much like carrie's series
but rather than being pulled back into
conflict between heaven and hell
tv's lucifer is inadvertently brought
into the fold of the lapd
that's why we'll make such great
partners that he said she said of it all
the yin yang the fireworks
partners were like glorified right along
across five seasons
the devil helps to solve crimes in
modern los angeles all while
fending off the occasional cosmic menace
or paranormal attack
lucifer generated enough fans to
circumvent its own cancellation
a real-world reflection of the main
character's slippery and resilient
nature
fox acts the series after three seasons
but netflix picked it up for two more
amid fan outcry
though the series was meant to close
after its 75th episode another
unlikely renewal revived it talk about
the devil's own luck
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic characters are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one